[Music]
i'm very tactile i've always had been
with my audience with my friends with
people i just am very tactile
it's been very hard to know
that there's some
navigating of that has to be
considered
if we're to keep the show on the road
it's very frustrating for me because
i'm not used to having to
consider anything like that you know
residencies back in vegas
a few festivals like cma fest
has just been the perfect
sort of uh
setup for us as a band to get ourselves
really sort of
oiled up and greasy as a band and
feeling really
loose and ready to go
yeah i mean anybody that's
tried to put together a guest list for a
certain party and can only buy x amount
of people
it's impossible
right
um
and so i think the the the way around
that for me was looking at moments in
the show where we could slip this song
out and we'll put this one in tonight
and then next night we'll take that one
out we'll put this one in and
at some point though i think you start
to get a feel for the flow that seems to
be working really really well it's
always been that way for me i mean
that's from the very beginning of my
career and it's true that this may this
person may never have seen us play
before this may be the only concert they
go to all year
i don't know what logistics this
person's gone through to make it here
tonight
yeah at all
i'm so hyper aware of all of the
logistics that people
go through to come to a concert they
didn't just show up and it was
effortless a lot of the times it takes
lots of planning lots of favors
lots of money borrowing lots of
everything just to make it to that
seat that they're in or that space
they're standing in
so i always want to make sure it's
a great night always
you